[Music]
what's up Wolfgang in today's video I
want to talk about something that has
been on my mind since even before I saw
Avengers infinity war but before we get
started with the video I must warn you
that there will be some spoilers in this
video and they will happen right when I
start talking about the theory but of
course before we get started don't
forget to enter our giveaway for your
chance to win a full speaker system all
you have to do to enter is subscribe to
my channel subscribe to the stupendous
wave leave a like and drop a comment
below of your favorite superhero that
could be Marvel DC or otherwise okay for
those of you who have not seen it you've
been warned so in this video I want to
talk about if Loki did in fact die or if
he didn't so it clearly looked like
Thanos did in fact choke him to death
but right after that as defeated the
Hulk and Heimdall sent him back to earth
Loki comes out of the shadows we all
know that Loki is the god of mischief
so that makes me wonder did he do
anything while he was in the shadows why
was he in the shadows one second he's
kind of tricking Thanos about to give
him the tesseract and then he jumps on
top of Thor and then the Hulk fights
Thanos The Hulk gets his butt kicked by
Thanos and then
Heimdall sends him back to earth and
then well Danushka time delay
Thanos is talking to the Black Order or
as they call him in the movie the
children of Thanos and saying go to
earth because there's two more Infinity
stones there bring them to me on Titan
and then Loki just comes out of the
background so here's what I'm getting at
we've seen Loki die before we've seen it
in Thor to the dark world and I know
summer you were thinking well his
illusions that he projects of himself
can't really be touched because they're
not physical but I'm not necessarily
talking about him using an illusion of
himself in Thor to the dark world we see
him physically get injured and then Thor
even holds him in his arms when he dies
so Thor literally was holding him felt
the wound in his chest and watched him
die but of course at the end we find out
that Loki really is alive and in Thor
Ragnarok we see that he's alive and he's
not hurt at all maybe
he's just had time to heal since then or
maybe he's just gotten a lot better at
his magic so it really wouldn't surprise
me if Loki is in fact still alive
because he did the same thing to Thanos
that he did the Thor in the dark world
then I think about the fact that Loki
isn't actually Asgardian
he's a frost giant so a part of me
wonders that if he ever does or did
truly die would his body not turn blue
and Thor to when he apparently dies his
body starts to change it changes color
doesn't necessarily turn blue but it
changes color and it looks like it kind
of gets some markings on it and it kind
of looks like it starts decay
clearly Loki did that in Thor 2 to trick
Thor into making him believe that he was
dead so I wonder if he did that to make
it seem like he was kind of turning back
into a frost giant and then there's one
last thing that makes me wonder whether
or not Loki is really dead when he's
about to give the tesseract to Thanos he
looks at Thor and he says I assure you
brother the Sun will shine on us again
at first glance it just seems like he's
talking about the Hulk he says we have a
Hulk then he dives out of the way to
save Thor and the Hulk starts smashing
on Thanos but if you think about it it
doesn't really make sense that Loki
would think that the Hulk could beat
Thanos especially with the black order
or the children of Thanos there as well
in the first Avengers movie Loki is on
Thanos aside he knows how powerful he is
and he knows how strong the black order
is yes the Hulk is amazingly strong but
Loki knows how strong Stannis's and he
just watched Thanos basically destroy
Asgard defeating Thor and Heimdall in
that process so when he says I assure
you brother the Sun will shine on us
again I don't think he's talking about
the Hulk defeating Thanos I think Loki's
up to something I think that the Hulk
was just a distraction for Thanos in the
black order so Loki could go and do
something some sort of magic or maybe he
you know duplicated himself somehow
while he teleported away to safety I
just I don't think he's dead and I think
that he's going to be a key character in
Avengers 4 and let's face it everybody
loves Loki I don't think they just kill
him off but this is just my theory what
do you guys think about it let me know
in the comments below and let me know if
you have your own theories again if you
haven't seen
infinity war I don't know why you watch
this video but go see it now and a
reminder about our giveaway be sure to
enter for your chance to win a speaker
system all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel subscribe to the
stupendous wave give this video a like
and leave a comment below of who your
favorite superhero is thank you so much
for watching
woof woof very well perhaps you prefer
one of your new companions given that
you seem to like them so much this is
better whoa the costumes a bit much so
tight but the confidence I can feel a
righteousness surging